in december 1984 ken webster a high
school teacher was living with his
friend nick and girlfriend debbie in the
small village of doddleston one evening
the three were walking home from the
local pub when they saw a pulsing green
light emanating from their cottage
windows when they got inside they saw
something to terrify them though their
computer wasn't connected to any network
and everyone in the house was gone all
night a strange message was written on
the screen a message addressed to them
by name over the next few months more
messages appeared and eventually ken and
his friends began corresponding with the
person on the other side at first ken
thinks this is a hoax or a prank but
over time he comes to believe that not
only the message is real they're being
written by someone living in the very
same house in the year 1541
let's find out why
[Music]
as written ken webster's book the
vertical plane strange things started
happening as soon as they moved into
meadow cottage at doddleston near the
border of england and wales one day ken
noticed that small six-toed footprints
seemed to walk directly up the wall and
through the ceiling it's a very old
house so we thought they were just
little stains so he painted over them
but the next day the footprints were
back on top of new paint after that
ken nick and debbie would routinely see
bottles cans and boxes stacked in towers
sometimes over four feet tall they
assumed that friends in the village were
playing pranks but nobody came forward
two months after the first message
appeared ken debbie and nick returned
home from a day trip and found a new
file had been saved on the bbc computer
the file name was r-e-a-t-e
they opened it
what strange words thou speak
although i must confess that i hath also
been ill-schooled
thou art goodly man who hath fanciful
woman who dwell in mine home tis a
fitting place with lights which devil
maketh and costly things that only my
friend edmund grey can afford or the
king himself
now this was not the way people spoke in
the eighties but there was more
it was a great crime to hath bribed mine
house
lw
ken printed the message and brought it
to school where most people thought it
was entertaining and nonsense but not
peter trinder trinder was a literature
teacher who was convinced it was written
in old english they interpreted the
phrase devil lights to mean the computer
and peter trinder asked ken to let him
know if any more messages appeared so he
can try and determine the location and
the time period of the dialect a few
days went by but nothing but then ken
had an idea he wondered if since he was
able to receive messages
could he also send them
so he sat down on the computer and began
to type
now at this point in the story ken is
still not convinced that this isn't a
hoax but he admits that he's intrigued
so he plays along he sits at the
computer and types question after
question trying to get information about
who this is that could be sending
messages from wherever they're coming
from
dear lw thank you for your message we're
sorry for disturbing you what would you
like us to do did you live on a house on
this land about 1620 do you want us to
tell you more about our time who is
edmund gray do you have a family is the
king james or charles what is the charge
house was this village called doddleston
in your life thank you very much for
your messages thank you for not making
us afraid ken debbie and john
they save the messages to disk then lead
the computer on and head out to the red
lion pub the hope is that if they leave
the computer alone for a while that it
would prompt a reply and that's exactly
what happened when they returned home a
few hours later a new message was
waiting for them it was an honest farm
of oak and stone it is helpful that you
should tell me about thy time dust thou
have horse edmund grey brother of john
gray lives at kineton hall thy king of
course is henry viii who is 6 and 40. i
know what of king james
my charge house is a place of law
schooling
lw
the 28th of march i know 15 1521
this was a troubling reply in more ways
than one first the facts about the
history of this time were wrong in 1521
henry viii was only 30 years old not 46
but to be sure ken delivered the message
to peter trinder for analysis and
trinder confirmed that the historical
facts were all wrong kinderton hall
wouldn't be built for another 200 years
and there's no mention of edmund or john
gray in any record or document and ken
was troubled by the use of modern
grammar and punctuation like question
marks which wouldn't have been used in
the 16th century so that left the other
possibility that there was an intruder
in the house and this had ken debbie in
it concerned but that weekend can borrow
the bbc computer once again to see if
more messages would come did they get
more messages
they did they received a whole bunch of
details about the house the village the
time and most importantly instead of
being signed by the mysterious lw
they were signed with the author's full
name
in the next message the author gave all
kinds of details about his life he
talked about losing his wife and son to
the plague he talks about how he
harvests barley for ale and makes his
own cheese he describes the house as
humble made of red stone and sitting on
a pretty parcel of land now meadow
cottage where ken nick and debbie were
living was not made of redstone but they
were doing renovations when they dug up
some of the land in the garden and
looked under the kitchen they discovered
the foundation of another structure much
much older than theirs tell me they
found redstone
and the foundation was indeed made of
red sandstone
now these latest messages also had a
different tone the author seemed to
think that ken was intruding on his
house and had his own concerns about
this conversation he finally signed the
message lucas and eventually we learned
that lw's full name is lucas wayneman
ken now had a lot of details that could
be checked for accuracy so he delivered
them to peter trinder to see what he can
find and trinder felt that the dialect
sentence structure and intermittent use
of latin placed the messages in the
middle of the 16th century in the
cheshire area which is exactly where
lucas wayman said he was living also as
time went on the historical facts became
more consistent and accurate and lucas
writes that king henry viii is married
to catherine parr so that put him in the
1540s which is pretty consistent with a
lot of the other details but the names
lucas mentioned like richard wishell and
others couldn't be found so this is a
hoax well not necessarily it was a hoax
you'd think that the messages would be
full of names and facts that could be
easily checked but lucas was a simple
rural farmer he'd really only have
knowledge of the king and people in his
village a tiny hamlet like dodelstone
wouldn't keep detailed records of every
individual living there now lucas
doesn't know where ken is
but eventually ken reveals that he's
actually writing from the year 1985 and
that's where the story takes a turn
you said your time be 1985.
we thought you were also from 2109
like your friend
what the
what friend it would appear that
whatever phenomenon that ken webster
encountered that allowed communication
to the past was also a conduit for
communication to the future
as more texts came in and as more of the
information was researched by peter
trinder ken was believing less that this
was a hoax the responses were coming too
fast for someone to be breaking in and
leaving files in his computer and ken
and debbie was starting to believe that
they were somehow communicating with a
real man a man who lived 400 years ago
on the same piece of land where ken was
living now but who were the people from
lucas didn't seem to know lucas thought
they were friends of ken's so ken did
the obvious thing he asked
calling 2109
and then came a response
ken deb peter
we are sorry that we can give you only
two choices
one that you either have your
predicament explained in such a way that
you have instant understanding but cause
what should not happen
or two try to understand that you three
have a purpose that shall in your
lifetime changes the face of history
we 2109
must not affect your thoughts directly
but give you some sort of guidance that
will allow room for your own destiny
all we can say is that we are all part
of the same god
whatever he or whatever it is
apparently ken's computer had opened
two-way communication not only with the
past but with the future as well and
according to 2109 this communication had
purpose though we don't yet know what
that purpose is meanwhile meadow cottage
was experiencing more and more events
that seemed to be a poltergeist
footsteps were heard at all hours of the
night but when they were investigated
nothing was there except footprints
sections of the house would become so
cold that breath was visible more
objects were found stacked in corners of
rooms tapping was heard even words were
found written in chalk around the house
including lucas's name the anxiety was
becoming too much deb had rented another
house nearby so they could occasionally
get some sleep and nick who'd been with
them since the beginning and moved out
deb tried to find some explanation for
what was happening and pulled some maps
of the area she learned that a ley line
was running
what's a ley line well a ley line is an
alignment drawn between two structures
that supposedly possess or can harness
energy stonehenge the great pyramids
chichen itza and other significant
structures are built on ley lines was it
cottage built in a ley line it was and
after discovering this deb started
having visions and vivid dreams about
lucas even interacting with him like he
was trying to communicate further it's
at this point that ken and dead bring in
help the society of psychical research
they called in heavies they did and the
spr sent two researchers to meadow
cottage and the plan was either to
debunk or prove the phenomenon once and
for all
[Music]
the society for psychical research or
spr had been investigating the
paranormal since 1882
and they're still around today oh gee
ghost hunters they are and two
investigators david welch and john
bucknell from the spr arrived and
proposed a test they would send 10
questions to 2109 and then delete them
but ken and deb would have no idea what
the questions were ken and deb were then
separated from the computer while they
waited for a reply and a few days later
david john
david you interfere with communication
next time you decide to perform your
little experiment you must be clear from
here we suggest you try someone else to
sit with debbie yes we are what you
would call a tacky on universe but your
understanding is incorrect we ask
nothing more of you than to carry on as
you would prefer
we will have john present if given
choice or you may bring another as
mentioned
no it is no concern to us that this is
not proved
we will give you a plotting of a star
next time
we move at a speed so that we cover
every point in your time and universe
we have no form we feed of a heat energy
that you will not have heard of
[Music]
david welch said that 2109 didn't answer
the questions but had picked up on all
the questions in the right order and ken
and dead thought this would prove that
they were not perpetrating a hoax the
spr investigators weren't so sure they
speculated that maybe sensitive
microphones could have been planted to
let them know the questions in advance
they spoke the questions out loud no
they didn't but the investigators
thought that maybe a microphone could
pick up the sounds of the keys being
pressed and that ken would be able to
deduce what they were typing that sounds
like a stretch to me it does but for
something like this it's best to
eliminate every possibility the spr
investigators left and ken looked for
more ways to convince them that what was
happening was real frank davis another
teacher at ken's school agreed to come
over as a witness when he arrived at the
study where the computer was set up he
reported that the room became extremely
cold for two or three minutes before
returning to normal they all went into
the kitchen for a while to talk when
they came back to check the computer a
new message had arrived but
this time
it was from someone else
when ken debbie and frank davis checked
the computer that evening a new message
was shown on the screen and it wasn't
from lucas it was from someone who
called himself john who was a friend of
lucas's john said that the local sheriff
had lucas imprisoned for witchcraft and
communicating with spirits so for days
no new messages arrived and ken and
debbie attributed this to lucas rotting
in a prison cell somewhere meanwhile
peter trinder was still feverishly
trying to decipher the past messages and
trinder enlisted the help of a librarian
at bresnos college at oxford and lucas
claimed to have attended brazenos and
gave ken a list of books to check to
prove he was telling the truth now after
some time the librarian confirmed that
not only did every single book exist at
the college but they were all
contemporary to the 1520s exactly as
lucas described finally
ken and deb decided to take an
aggressive approach they demanded that
word be taken to the sheriff that lucas
be freed or they would use their power
against him that seemed to get the
sheriff's attention and lucas was
immediately freed now sensing a new
kinship ken asked lucas if he was the
one moving objects around the house
lucas says it wasn't him but the same
thing was happening on his side both ken
and lucas began to suspect that the
poltergeist activity was being caused by
the mysterious entity that they called
so lucas asked ken to move the bbc
computer to the kitchen which on lucas's
side would let him communicate more
privately a 2109 had warned ken and
lucas to not give each other details
about their lives but they were growing
distrustful lucas then proposed an idea
that sounded completely bizarre he asked
that a paper and pen be set next to the
computer now ken didn't understand this
but he did as he was instructed the next
morning next to the computer was a
handwritten note the writing was elegant
and archaic and the note was signed
thomas
early in their communications lucas
whose real name was thomas was reluctant
to give his real name he said that this
was out of fear of being accused of
witchcraft which actually came to pass
but thomas left clues about his full
name in his letter he said you have my
name in your book it is also the name of
peter's house peter lived close by in a
town called harwoodyn which was also the
location of the school where ken and
peter taught using this information ken
and peter were able to track down a man
named thomas harwarden who was a fellow
at bresnos college at oxford in the
1530s this was their guy and ken debbie
and peter were getting very close to the
truth and learning everything they could
about thomas howard but the entity known
as 2109 seemed to be upset by this a few
days later the computer was moved into
the bathroom on its own and then ken
found a message scribbled in chalk on
the floor
one more chance
measure frequency by plus two energy
what else other than sound and light
this 2109 is freaking me out i know
ken deb peter we have reason to believe
you have lucas weinman's true name if
this is correct you must say so so we
can rectify the problem immediately
before it is accepted
she is touchy yeah and ken wanted to
minimize his contact with 2109 after
more communication with thomas hardin in
the 16th century ken learned that 2109
was tampering with many of the earlier
messages that thomas aka lucas had sent
apparently 2109 was trying to obscure
details to prevent ken from discovering
thomas's true identity which is why some
facts were wrong meanwhile the society
for psychical research had lost interest
in the case they told a local paper
clearly if this case is a hoax then the
two teachers are the prime suspects i
believe it is also possible that a third
party was responsible i would have loved
to prove it was genuine it would have
been the most unique phenomenon ever
recorded something or someone is doing
it it was not the job of the spr to
point the finger
as ken suspected the spr was extremely
skeptical and wasn't taking the
investigation seriously so ken contacted
the spr to obtain the records of the
case
strangely the spr said there is no
record of such a case
investigator john bucknell had
disappeared and nobody can reach him and
there was no record of anyone named
david welch affiliated with the spr as
far as the spr is concerned none of this
ever happened and everyone connected to
the case was gone apparently 2109 was
aware of ken's frustration because a few
days later they contacted him and this
time they gave him the name of someone
to contact no and a phone number
when ken sat down at the bbc computer
2109 had left him a very specific
message
we asked you to do the following there
is a brilliant researcher ufologist we
know you don't like the word his name is
gary m rowe his ideas differ somewhat to
yours but nevertheless he can help you
with a couple of your problems you may
phone him at the number below and invite
him to talk with you when he comes show
him this and ask him what he makes of it
peter must do the telephoning tell them
that you got a telephone number from a
ufo enthusiast
gary lowe was a ufo investigator who was
skeptical but he did come out to meadow
cottage with all kinds of equipment to
try and figure out what was going on
this began a series of communication
between gary and 2109 directly the
process was this gary would put a letter
in a sealed envelope and place it on top
of the computer when 2109 would respond
the message was printed and put into an
envelope without ken reading it this
back and forth continued for some time
when gary finally sent the message back
to 2109 that read
greetings i am instructed to apologize
but in any event i would have done so my
volition there will be a letter
hopefully this weekend i am also
instructed to apologize to ken and
debbie i must try and answer your last
letter it would appear that you are more
important than i had realized in the
scheme of things gary
apparently something in one of the
messages from 2109 had caused gary to
become very secretive about the
communication and the contents of the
letters ken became so frustrated and
angry that gary left that night
and they would never hear from gary
again
as ken continued to communicate with
thomas aka lucas lucas explained that
one night he saw glowing lights coming
from his fireplace from the light a man
stepped out and asked him to not be
afraid when the man left lucas found
what he described as a light box in his
kitchen he realized that when he spoke
to the light box his words would appear
on a screen in glowing green letters and
on march 21st 1985 lucas had sent his
final message
my true fellows and sweet maid grona has
said that thomas must go i know it is
for the best because the people of
doddlestone are very wary of me it is
good to know that all will change and
there are true men to follow like ken
and peter though 400 years is a long
time and there is much to happen to
mankind perhaps you will come to oxford
now i think there is no danger for me
there for i hear the king is very sick
and all is quiet in the church
i shall go by boat from cheshire to
bristol i shall try to make my stay at
brace nose i will write my book about my
brothers and maid and the end of lucas
and our love for one another one day you
will all sit down at my table for wine
and mead by the river in oxford where we
shall read each other's books and laugh
and we shall speak of truth and good men
watching oxford change together
forevermore in your time my book is old
but i shall not go to my god until it is
written then we will all be truly
embraced my love to you all i shall
await you in oxford thomas harden
[Music]
well that was touching i thought so did
he ever write the book well we have one
final message from 2109
there is another person to come they
will be the help we need you will know
when they come thomas did eventually
write his book and he soon died shortly
after
he placed it in a secure place it
shouldn't take too many years to find it
though he wrote it in latin with the
help of a friend that he met in oxford
the inscription reads me writes this
with the hope that mine friends will one
day find this book
then may our lands be not so distant
we will finish now you have a lot of
work to do there is no need to write
back as we will have gone thank you for
your cooperation
and no more communication would follow
in all lucas and 2109 had sent over 300
messages to ken and debbie and a few
years later ken would document the story
in his book the vertical plane the story
would again be covered in 1996 in a bbc
documentary called from out of this
world and ken and debbie appeared on the
program but with their backs to the
camera they claimed that the messages
were real and they held important
information about our past and future
you can find debbie online posting as
recently as a few weeks before i
recorded this and she sounds reasonable
rational and convinced
while their story has many skeptics ken
and debbie insist that one day their
story will be revealed to be the truth
i hope they're right
[Music]
wow this is a good story so how much of
it is real all of it none of it all of
it all of it
well here's what i've been able to dig
up peter trinder essentially worked as a
translator of the messages
the original script was so far and
sounding that he had to dig through
years of the oxford english dictionary
to decipher meanings of lots of the
words and trinder said that this would
be almost impossible to fake especially
for someone with no background in
medieval languages
peter trinder even went on camera with
the bbc to say so it was very real
that's all i'm saying richard it was
very close the kind of thing that you
could not doubt
but all the time one was aware of the
possibility of hoax but if it was a hoax
by golly it was brilliant and on the
skeptical side also from the same
program there's dr laura wright of
cambridge looking at the verb structure
there are things which lucas says that
would not have been said in 1546
it's true that individuals can make up
individual words but we don't make up
our verbs
it's possible or it was possible in
england in 1546 to say i do
thou dust he she or it doth he she or it
does but it wasn't possible to say i
doth or he she or it dust now all the
way through um lucas's messages he mixes
and messes up these suffixes with the
wrong subject finally when asked if she
thought it was a hoax by someone with a
background in early english writing no
if somebody had a background in early
modern english writings they would do
they would their hopes would look a lot
better than this i mean they would get
their verbal inflections correct they
wouldn't choose vocabulary that came
from a period long before the period
that this is supposed to have been
written in um they'd do it a lot better
also a sample of ken's writing was run
through software and compared against
lucas's messages the result was that
both sets of writing tested close enough
with the software that they were
possibly composed by the same author now
ken said that 300 words isn't nearly
large enough of a sample and that the
bbc specifically chose passages that
they were sure would give them the
results they hoped for media always has
an agenda that's true now ken and
debbie's roommate showed up in a forum a
few years ago saying that meadow cottage
was actually a peaceful place that he
never experienced any of the phenomena
that ken did so ken's lying well john
doesn't go that far he said ken was a
serious person and wouldn't want to open
himself up to ridicule by writing a book
that would make him out to be alone
another rumor which i read online i
don't know if it's true is that when the
librarian was researching the books on
lucas's list it's been reported that
someone else was there also researching
the same books
that's just what i read on a blog post
i'm not judging i'm just reporting but
here's something interesting
in the book which was published in 1989
entity 2109 says that in ken's lifetime
verma's last theorem would be solved
pierre de fermat proposed a mathematical
theorem in 1637 and it was studied by
mathematicians for over 350 years and
couldn't be solved well in 1995 andrew
wiles published the first successful
proof of format's last theorem a proof
that earned wiles the able prize 2109
was right they were and that's an
obscure detail for a hoaxer to just come
up with and it's a hell of a gamble also
2109 gave the coordinates of an
undiscovered star that they said would
be important to mankind and years later
a quasar was found at those coordinates
and lucas talks about being imprisoned
by a sheriff thomas fowlehurst of
cheshire now there's no record of this
man but i did some sleuthing and it
turns out that there absolutely was a
sir thomas falhurst with a slightly
different spelling but same
pronunciation who was sheriff of
cheshire in 1529 which is awfully close
to the right time hey do you ever find
that ufo guy ah gary rowe
though ufo researcher gary road
disappeared for years he's since spoken
out about the donaldson messages in the
description i'll link to a blog post
from as recently as 2017 where gary has
all kinds of things to say he believes
every word of it he thinks he was chosen
to receive this information from 2109
because the information is safe with him
many people are highly skeptical about
the events related in the vertical plane
book quite rightly so given the degree
of strangeness
but i am not i left no stone unturned
and used cutting-edge science to get to
the truth in fact i believe it was the
first computer-controlled psychic
investigation recorded in the world i
know it really happened it changed my
life forever it is going to change yours
the book will one day be isbn recorded
under the history section it is a
monumental historical marker in the
ribbon of time
is he right
i guess time will tell
i don't know if the doddleston messages
story can be debunked but it can
certainly be contested but i have to
admit a lot of the story can be
confirmed ken and debbie haven't cashed
in and they seem to be very nice
intelligent reasonable people and after
the bbc program they sought no further
publicity about the story even knowing
how many books they can sell and ken
said back then
now just over 10 years after our own
adventures the sad but good advice seems
to be to keep quiet about it meadow
cottage was important to us it is
sufficient and although debbie can be
found online ken prefers privacy and i
think we should respect that all we can
hope for is that one day buried under
the dusty faded stacks in the brazenos
library in oxford
someone will discover a mysterious book
handwritten in latin a book that tells a
fantastic tale of a relationship between
people across time people though
initially fearful and skeptical of one
another establish a friendship that
would change all their lives
and this book
when finally discovered will change
everyone's life everywhere forever
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is aj that cyclefish this
has been the y files if you had fun or
learned anything do me a favor and like
subscribe comment and share all that
stuff really helps just trying to solve
the youtube algorithm is like trying to
communicate with 2109 using a word
processor but with your help
we can defeat it
[Music]
you